hello everyone and welcome to the game
you guys requested uh yesterday in
yesterday's video I didn't think I was
gonna be making a video on this one but
so many of you requested it here it is
it is a game from the final round of the
super super Blitz tournament Magnus
costume versus young shisht of Duda and
you know that the dude that was leading
the entire tournament he won the Rapids
he was leading after the first day of
Blitz but then Magnus just went on a
killing spree uh in the final day uh
pretty much uh adopted everyone and uh
in the final round he met to do that
with 22 and a half points dude I had 21
and a half points and if Duda wins they
go into tie breaks so let's see uh what
happened here it's quite uh quite a wild
game uh if you haven't seen it you will
enjoy it uh so Magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with E4 Duda goes
for a very strange variation of the
Sicilian Defense Knight to a three and
pawn to B6 this is the catalimo
variation uh which uh you know is used
often to confuse your opponent but also
to start by developing your queen side
first we have Pawn the D4 captures
captures and now Bishop to B7 attacking
the E4 Pawn Knight to C3 and now Ponte
A6 taking away the B5 Square from the
both white Knights and now Bishop to G5
so you can see that black still hasn't
uh started developing the center or the
king's side we have Queen to C7 and now
Magnus plays Knight to D5 he attacks do
the screen here and Duda just plays
Queen to E5 he puts pressure on the
bishop and G5 but also maybe he can win
that Knight on D5 so here we have Bishop
to E3 and now Pawn to E6 does it doesn't
want to capture the Knight because if he
does yes he wins the pawn but at what
price Magnus will get a whole lot of
development in and is just not something
you want to do against the well against
anyone but uh let alone against the
Magnus in a Blitz game let's say E5 you
can even trade off the Queens doesn't
really matter captures captures so YT
still has so much development in for the
price of that one pawn and of course the
mighty Bishop Perry this bishop is
coming to F3 this should be spawning
pressure on B6 so there is no upside
here for black so instead Ponte E6 was
played
uh Knight to F3 attacking the queen and
now Duda can no longer keep an eye on
the C7 Square even if he just goes back
Bishop to F4 and Knight the C7 check is
coming so do the accepted Knight
captures on e4 Queen captures 94 Knights
the C7 with check and now King the E7
Magnus gobbles up the Rogue Bishop
captures and now Queen to D4 Magnus was
able to trade off the queens and now he
wants to go into the end game and there
is a game where Queen captures and D4
was played baduda plays B5 and it is now
as of move 12 that we have a completely
new game now Magnus plays A4 that makes
sense you always play this when you have
uh the black pawns on A6 and B5 you want
to either double them or mess up a black
spawn structure and do the trades Queens
with characters captures and fun to beat
sorry captures with the Knight and pawn
to B for grabbing more space on the
king's side A5 Magnus does the same
Knight to F6 and knights the B3 now is
the Magnus being up the exchange enough
to actually win this uh well let's see
Knights the the five wheel Bishop to A7
and now Knight the C6 and now we have
busher back to B6 now Magnus is ready to
capture on A6 and while Duda can defend
the laser Bishop to B7 then Knight C5 is
really annoying and again you're
defending the pawn uh when you could be
developing and you know a strong player
when given a choice of giving up a pawn
or giving up development everyone gives
up material
uh so G5 he wants to make use of this
diagonal and force Magnus defend we have
Bishop captures and A6 Bishop to G7 and
now Rook to A2 defending the pawn uh
Rook to B8 and Bishop to EQ finally
Knight captures mb6 a captors and
knights to D4 you still can't Dodge it
upon because the bishop on A8 would hang
so here Knight captures Bishop captures
and Bishop to F3 offering a trait of
Bishops Duda happily accepts G captures
and now Pawn to B3 yes Magnus does have
a three to one advantage on the queen
side but Duda takes care of that with a
single Pawn push and this wouldn't be
possible if the pawn was not on B4 of
course so upon the B3 C counters on B3
and The Rook captures and B6 we have
fonte H4 Magnus wants to open up the
king side and then go for some nice Rook
lifting H6 and now captures captures
uh King D2 and The Rook captures on B3
so gobbling up all of the all of the
pawns and getting ready to capture on B2
as well and the while you could defend
this with Rook to B1 I mean look at this
uh what what that's no way to to play
chess or to live uh so instead The Rook
to D1 Magnus gives up the B2 Pawn we
have Bishop to B6 and now Rook to D3
offering a trade but just to Rook to B5
not ready to capture the pawn just yet
Pawn to B3 and pawn to F5 we have Rook
day four and Bishop to C5 Duda knows
that uh uh the the this Pawn will never
be able to to cross B4 doesn't really
matter what the Magnus does so Pawn to
B4 Bishop to B6 and now Rook to B3 with
King to F6 Rook to eight and now Bishop
again to C5 attacking the B4 Pawn now
either you repeat with Rook to A4 or you
try something else here a Magnus player
Rook day five he forced uh
an end game where he will have a rook
against the bishop the problem is after
Rook captures Rook captures and Bishop
captures on B4 is that now Duda has four
pawns and Magnus has only two pawns and
that's a doubled F Pawn so not not the
greatest the sixth wave Rook to D7
Bishop to C5 Rook to H7 and King to E5
and if you're wondering if anyone is
playing for the win here uh it is only
Duda who's playing for a win here Magnus
can only wait and see what Duda will do
uh Rook to G7 going after the pawn here
King to F4 and now Rook to G6 we have
Pawn to E5 everything is nicely defended
but now if Duda wants to continue
pushing further he will have to trade
some pawns which means that Magnus will
undouble his Pawn so Rook G and Bishop
D4 Rook 38 and Bishop to C5 we have Rook
d8 Pawn to G4 and we have to start
trading rookie for check Bishop D4
captures capture Sun G4 and now Pawn to
F3 with check
uh King to F4 Rook to 8 and now Pawn to
E4 so the last Pawn for white will be
traded off F chapters and E4 F captures
on e4 and Rook the f8 with check with
King T5 and The Rook the E8 with check
King to D5 and now King to D2 and now a
Duda has to figure out a way how to
continue pushing those pawns now uh the
dream would be to have this Pawn on D3
this Pawn successfully pushed to E2 so
the pawns should be on light squares and
you will use your dark Square Bishop for
example to kick the King off of the dark
squares and then you win the game if you
can achieve this you win if not then
it's a draw so here Bishop to C5 King to
E2 King to D4 and Rook to A5 D5 another
Pawn push with Rook to A4 and King to E5
we have uh Rook day five Bishop to B6
Rook to B5 and now uh Bishop to G1 Rook
to B1 harassing the bishop Bishop to C5
Rook to H1 and another Pawn push Rook to
pawn to D4
Rook dh5 with check King 36 and now Rook
to F5 with Bishop to B4 Rook to H5 King
to E6 and now Rook to B5 so uh first you
have to uh get up a perfect setup on how
to advance that pawn but if Magnus
doesn't allow and then if he plays
precisely will not be able to do it so
here Rook to H3 does just that now while
you can advance the spawn to D3 with
check he will just give up the rook and
that's it now it's a draw by
insufficient material that's uh if if
there wasn't if this trick wasn't in the
position then it would be incred
impossible to defend so King D5 by
Magnus uh by Duda Rook to H5 checking E6
Rook H3 again King 36 Rook E3 King to C5
Rook day five check King the B4 we have
rooked the D5 and here Magnus made the
an inaccuracy that could cost him the
game he should have played Rook to F5
but now Luda finds uh the correct way to
win the game King the C4 attacks The
Rook Rook to F5 and now D3 with check
King D1 and now Doodle can play pretty
much any move with the bishop except the
one that he played the bishop to G3
now the problem is uh Magnus has a way
of saving the position and I'm sure you
guys know what it is but just in case
the brush up on your endgame skills feel
free to pause the video and don't lose
this position for white uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game as I have no
doubt all of you are and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook the G5 it's merely a matter of
winning a Tempo so Rook the G4 can be
played and you can pin that E4 E4 Pawn
so Bishop to F2 we have rooked the G4
now the King has to come over and help
defend the pawn and you don't have time
for E3 E2 uh King to D5 and now Rook the
G8 with King the D4 again uh Magnus
blunders the game but this is Blitz only
a few seconds on the clock and uh it's
incredibly difficult to win this bishop
to D4 is the only winning move here for
Duda and yeah good luck finding that
with seconds on the clock I will however
show it because it's beautiful uh point
is that after Rook to d8 to check you
will create this a sort of a barrier
Rook to see a check and now Bishop to C5
and now you have the E3 Square defended
and there's no way to stop quantity E3
Pawn to E2 so even if Rook to H it even
if you try something like this let's say
Pawn to E3 and now Rook the age for
check king of Bishop to D4 can be used
to block and after uh Rook the G4 King
D5 you will give a few more checks check
check Bishop to E5 Rook to G8 and now
King the E4 Rook 38
um
that means the bishop came there for now
rooked f8 to check King to G4 Rook to J
to check King to F3 and after one more
check Bishop the F4 will be played and
now E2 check is winning there is no
defense against that because the king is
also covering the two squares so you
will not be able to give up The Rook so
whatever you play either this is winning
or now even this is winning it doesn't
really matter what you play King D1 80
would check everything is nicely
defended you're gonna move D1 Queen and
of course easy easy win however do the
misted king the D4 was played and now
Rook to date with Chuck Magnus again uh
gets another lease on life Bishop H4
Rook E6 and again he will just harass
that bishop and not allow the pawn to be
pushed from E4 so again Rook to d8 now
stops the E Pawn from being pushed
because Rook captures on D3 so King F4
Rook D7 King E3 Rook d8 Bishop C3 Rook
to D7 and King F4 now if uh Magnus
doesn't mess it up it will be a draw so
a lot of moves were played because it's
a very very long game so basically a you
know a game of cat and mouse so King C3
King E5 Rook f8 Bishop F4 Rook F7 Bishop
E3 Rook f8 Bishop D4 with the check move
100 has been reached King to D2 Bishop
to C5 and Rook to F7 so
a rook F4 Bishop to be for checking the
one Bishop C3 Rook H4 King D5 another
check Roxy 5 Bishop D4 Rook A5 and now
King to D6 uh the problem again here
with E3 is that Rook to A3 can be played
and there's no way to defend the D3 Pawn
you can't uh do do anything about that
and if you play D2 then you have your
pawns on dark squares we discussed that
the pawns need to be in light Square so
the bishop can maneuver between them on
the dark squares but now King E2 and you
are never getting rid of this king from
a light Square so after Rook day five
King the D6 was played and now we have
Rook to A8 we have King to E5 and The
Rook the E8 with check sorry there seems
to be a fly attacking me from from
somewhere uh King to F4 and now Rook to
B8 Bishop to C3 Rook defeat check King
to E3 and The Rook to E8 again no way to
make progress here
stopping Rook 38 but now just to Rook
the E6 preparing Rook D6 if needed King
to D4 Rook D6 checking C4 rookie 6 King
to D5 and now you have to play Rook to
G6 however or Rook to H6 like those are
the modes you want to play however Rook
d8 was played and now Duda is again
completely winning but only if he finds
Bishop to C8 C7 or B6 he did not play
that he played King to D4 the reason why
this is so strong now because you are
able to repeat the exact same maneuver
that we already discussed the point is
that you will shift your king all the
way at the F3 I'll block it with Bishop
to F4 and then E2 E2 or D2 is
Unstoppable however he missed that he
played King to D4 now comes Rook to A8
Bishop to C7 and Rook to C8 and now
again Magnus blunders the game Bishop to
B6 is again winning because you can get
the exact same setup however Bishop to
F4 was played Rook 38 with check King to
C3 Rook to see it which king B3 and The
Rook f8 and here yeah dude I just gave
up uh on on trying Bishop to H6 or maybe
it's even the 50 move rule already I
don't know Rook date Bishop G7 Rook d8
King C3 and after Rook captures on e4 he
was in this position and move 124 that
the players agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here you
couldn't win with two extra pawns now
with one of course there is no chance
uh so yeah really a wild game where
Magnus definitely got to the early
Advantage after this uh winning of the
rook and A8 but it's hard the same Blitz
I mean probably with perfect plays just
a draw uh but then Duda got some actual
winning positions I think he was winning
five times throughout the game but
that's the problem with blitz a few
seconds on the clock it's not easy to uh
you know to make anything out of your
your position and the Magnus is just a
very very resilient Defender so yeah
dude I had a chance to catch up to
Magnus in the final round and four star
breaks but Magnus how to do a draw uh
and that's how he won the tournament for
those of you who missed them my previous
video uh you can see that at some point
in the tournament Magnus just went
berserk and he almost adopted the field
getting a nine and a half out of out of
ten victories from 10 games which is
absolutely incredible so he caught up to
do them and he uh you know which to do
this uh Onslaught in the final round uh
winning him the final uh the the uh the
first place uh so here you can see 24 uh
points for Magnus 20 three for due to
the second place third Wesleyan Maxima
Sherlock with 21 and a half with 20 and
a half we have level on the report with
18. uh Anish giri 15 kokiro with 13 the
bognan Daniel Dak 12 and a half and
check last place uh with 11 points so
yeah truly an incredible game and
incredible struggle and you know a great
a great attempt by Duda but you know
very very strong defense by Magnus um
sir what are you gonna do uh Magnus wins
and it seems that he is definitely back
from his vacation wherever he was you
know he was playing some poker probably
doing some sports you know just chilling
a little bit and he even said at some
point that maybe he even forgot how to
play chess but it doesn't seem to be the
case
and as Kasparov said uh his Embrace of a
Viking appearance seems to have paid off
in Warsaw uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it in this very
short coverage of the uh super bad rapid
and Blitz tournament that was played in
Poland I would like to thank
golfsoftware.com revision reptiles
YouTube
and Marcus Rebel for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day